to end the covert 19 pandemic and to
return to some kind of normal
we're gonna need a vaccine but how long
will it take to develop one 12 to 18
months is the timeline that we keep
hearing about for a potential kovat 19
vaccine when do we have a vaccine 12 to
18 months were 12 to 18 months away from
this going away but here's a comparison
the fastest vaccine we previously
developed was for mumps and that took
four years to develop and typically it
takes 10 to 15 years to develop a
vaccine so 12 to 18 months would be
record-breaking so let's look at how
vaccines for viruses are typically
developed stage 1 the exploratory stage
the exploratory stage is also known as
the research or discovery stage for a
vaccine here researchers are trying to
come up with the best possible way to
immunize us against a virus this first
stage can take between two to four years
but right now scientists are speeding
through stage 1 partly because of new
technologies and also because this SARS
coronavirus has some similarities to the
first SARS virus researchers are
developing nucleotide based vaccines
that use the virus's genetic code to
potentially protect us from infection
this is a new way of developing a
vaccine where the virus's RNA or DNA
prompts our bodies to make a part of the
virus and that's how we develop immunity
to it in January 2020 Chinese scientists
shared the genetic sequence of the new
corona virus this allowed researchers
around the world to understand what the
virus looked like and how it worked and
it gave them a head start to developing
a vaccine so if a nucleotide base
vaccines work that could mean that we're
done with this first exploratory stage
and that cuts up to four years off our
timeline but and this is a big but
nucleotide based vaccines
have never made it through clinical
trials and FDA approval so the
exploratory stage can take up to four
years but thanks to existing research
and new technologies for vaccine
development some Coe bid 19 vaccines may
already be through this stage stage 2
preclinical stage this is where
scientists start testing the vaccine and
cell cultures and in animals to see if
it triggers an immune response if
there's no immune response or the
vaccine is causing harm to cells then
it's back to square one the exploratory
stage so how quickly can we move through
the preclinical stage for a covert 19
vaccine well the reality is there's a no
way to speed up this stage and it will
probably take at least a year but one
way to make this more efficient is to
start doing different stages of vaccine
development simultaneously this is
exactly what some covert 19 vaccine
scientists are doing right now they're
testing the vaccine in animals at the
same time that they're testing the
vaccine in humans doing the testing in
animals and humans at the same time is
unusual but the FDA does have a
fast-track process in cases of public
health emergencies most vaccines don't
make it past the preclinical stage but
the American biotech company moderna is
working on a coded 19 vaccine and was
able to get from the first exploratory
stage to human trials in 63 days stage 3
clinical trials this third stage is
clinical trials or testing the vaccine
in people most vaccines don't ever reach
clinical trials but if they do then this
stage can take 19 months or more and it
consists of three phases in the first
phase the experimental vaccine is given
to a small group of people this phase
can take about three months if an
experimental vaccine is safe then it
moves on to phase 2 phase 2 typically
takes at least six to eight months
during phase two the vaccine is given to
several hundred people including a
control group who get a placebo not the
actual vaccine the control group helps
researchers compare how the vaccine
works and control for different
variables in Phase three
thousands of people usually folks in the
outbreak area will receive the
experimental vaccine this phase can also
last at least six to eight months if not
longer and at this point researchers are
looking to make sure the vaccine is
effective and to monitor any side
effects
these are best-case scenarios in terms
of the timeline for each phase of human
testing right now there are at least
three covin 19 vaccines in Phase one
clinical trials in the u.s. one way to
speed up phase 3 clinical trials is to
do something called a human challenge
trial that's where people are given the
vaccine but then the scientists
intentionally infect them with the virus
to see more quickly if the vaccine
really works it might sound like an
extreme way to speed up vaccine
development but it's been done many
times before including with cholera
dengue and flu human challenge trials
raised many ethical red flags in 2017
there was a proposed human challenge
trial to speed up a Zika vaccine and
Zika of course can cause severe birth
defects and that human challenge tall
was criticized by ethicists as being too
risky so doing the math the quickest way
that a coded 19 vaccine could make its
way to human testing without doing human
challenge trials is around 15 months but
there could be delays at any point along
this timeline stage 4 regulatory review
at this stage the vaccine manufacturer
submits an application to receive a
license so that they can manufacture the
vaccine typically it takes the FDA 10
months to conduct a standard review or
six months for a priority review but the
FDA can move faster in case of a public
health emergency and some FDA programs
allow for a rolling review that's where
the vaccine maker is submitting
information as they go along instead of
waiting for they finished and then
submitting the application the FDA is
responsible for overseeing the safety of
any drug or vaccine available in the US
so its review of this information as
absurd
critical before the vaccine can make its
way to a large population Naoko bid 19
vaccines in the US and near this stage
over in the UK scientists in the
University of Oxford are hopeful that
emergency approval of their vaccine by
UK regulators could mean it's available
in September the best case would be a
rolling review of a potential covert 19
vaccine taking less than the usual
timeline of 6 to 10 months stage 5
manufacturing this is a stage where drug
companies stop making and distributing
their vaccines it takes an incredible
amount of resources and investment in
infrastructure raw materials and
scientific expertise Manufacturing a
vaccine can take a long time according
to one estimate it can take between 7 to
36 months to produce and deliver a
vaccine it can also take a really long
time for companies to scale up their
manufacturing capabilities the drug
company Pfizer told the New York Times
that it took them six hundred million
dollars and five years just to produce a
manufacturing plant for one of their
pneumococcal vaccines and currently we
are not at the manufacturing stage for a
covert 19 vaccine but if we were how
quickly would we move to be honest this
is an unknown and depends very much on
the capacity of the drug company
involved Stage six quality control so
we're not done yet
once the vaccine is distributed to the
public there's the ongoing stage of
quality control and this is done in the
US by the CDC the FDA and the vaccine
maker so how long will it take for a
vaccine is available for the public well
we can go through each stage and add up
the time taken but often these are time
ranges and we're seeing right now that
sometimes one stage is done at the same
time as another stage when experts
optimistically say that they expect a
covert 19 vaccine by the end of 2020
they're talking about an emergency use
authorized vaccine not fully approved
one and very limited supplies of one
seeing a vaccine in 12 to 18 months
would mean producing new
of doses by January or June of 2021 if
things continue to move as quickly as
they are now there's a possibility that
there could be a Kovac 19 vaccine in two
years likely in early 2022 the major
delays and potentially seeing a vaccine
by the new year would be the time it
takes to safely move through clinical
trials and the manufacturing stage
clinical trials usually take a minimum
of 15 months and that's if everything
goes perfectly with their vaccine
working exactly the way it was designed
and not causing major side effects the
manufacturing stage is another unknown
producing a safe and effective vaccine
for millions or billions of people could
take at minimum 7 months I know we're
excited and desperate for a vaccine to
be available within 12 to 18 months but
what's even more important than rushing
is that we have a vaccine that's safe
and a vaccine that works and until then
we're going to have to stick with the
things that we know work including those
containment measures such as physical
distancing